[Música]
boa tarde a todos
hum e obrigada por este convite por
apostar aqui então o caso volta porque
não está habituado a estas andanças mas
vou tentar falar um pouco da minha
história não é muito interessante mas
vou falar no mesmo jantar não tem 44
anos são natural do vila nova sobre
carro mas muito pequenininha vim para
guimarães ea que cria as minhas raízes
com um cara muito natural eu sou o mais
velho de cinco irmãos e há 30 anos atrás
era normal em práticas acabar o ensino
obrigatório ir trabalhar
foi o que aconteceu comigo acaba o
ensino obrigatório 3 14 anos e foi
trabalhar querendo eu numa numa cidade
mas uma cidade muito ligado aos têxteis
não era difícil encontrar trabalho nessa
área
quem sabe até encerrar a trabalhar
também com a sua gente guimarães deve
ter familiares de trabalhar na área
têxtil
naquela altura foi muito fácil encontrar
trabalho numa numa confecção era fácil
encontrar trabalho nessa altura e então
eu fui trabalhar como conversava em que
era a mina de recados que se puxarmos
uma grega aos dias de hoje podemos
chamar a assistência operacional de
costureira evento e foi trabalhar muito
contente seguinte será chamada gostei e
pensei logo não é isso que eu quero
fazer
eu quero mesmo é ser estranho é tarde a
máquina não é táchira por 3 a 1 e assim
foi com 16 anos eu já dominava qualquer
máquina na linha de produção já fazia
uma peça história do princípio ao fim
sempre o m1
até que por volta dos 17 18 anos e ainda
não tiver sido diferente uma colega
trabalho convidou para abrir mão da
nossa própria confessá afetivo era uma
altura em que isso acontecia muito mas
conversei seu feitio as peças eram bem
paga naquela altura e como eu era muito
versátil trabalhava em qualquer máquina
ela convidam e eu lá fui abrir uma
confecção aos oito anos já era
empresário
mas além de trabalhar e também namorava
claro contou
e casa muito nova com toda a minha vida
estava acontecendo rápido há 21 anos
casei e resolvemos constituir família
a cdu com 31 anos que já era mãe de x
até que quando o seu primeiro filho eu
achei por bem e achei que a confessar
que estava a tomar muito tempo e também
já era uma altura por volta de 21 anos
que confessou o fmi já não estava a dar
tanto dinheiro com deu o início já
estava mais
mas a função da crise se calhar podemos
dizer assim
então eu com 20 marcando o seu primeiro
filho aos 23 por volta de ben resolvi ir
pra casa ceder um pouco número um
trabalho bastante que ocupa bastante nós
como você vê esse dia o que pra casa não
quis deixar de misturar achei que iria
costurar mas outra forma não em massa
não em grandes quadrados nas mais
personalizada dedicada indicar um sol o
trabalho mais específico da alta costura
podemos dizer assim uma parte mas mas
mas professa
então vim pra casa como é ter de ganhar
porque é este a se retirar nos últimos
20 anos tem porque já tenho um filho com
21 anos estudos 20 anos em casa deram a
possibilidade de experimentar técnicas
de trabalho novas escolher se diz
errados
as peças erradas mas e tv porque agora
vocês querem experimentar postura com a
internet e as redes sociais e evitar a
pesquisa milena que a outra não havia
nada é minha gente pra mim tá tá certo
não dá certo a gente passava um dia
trabalhar no dia seguinte era tudo pode
fazer tudo para voltar ao início
futebol algumas vezes mas nunca tinha
estado tanto aquela área que nunca quer
que este quis que desistirem continue
sempre até porque era aquilo me sustenta
que dava o sustento da minha casa eu
podia podia dar uma lancha de
experimentar essa técnica não vão chegar
onde cheguei hoje lugar num tecido
saberá onde pertence ao circo em poucas
horas de ter uma peça na história pronta
que é difícil por isso estou a dizer que
a área costeira não ficámos
surpreendidos um dia para o outro amor
diziam os cometem para chegar à
perfeição não acho que é
acima de tudo gostar muito de ganhar diz
o estatuto de costureira eu tenho sempre
daí a quem procurava em casa para fazer
roupa e é sempre com aquela aquela que o
estigma podemos chamar eu não gosto
muito específico com os três não correu
bem porque eu fui mas não ela já deu
tempo de o contrário do que acontece com
o alfaiate por perguntar um homem fez um
fato mas vou adquirir a oferta também
chegou a consultar minha vida no meu
corpo costureira não acontece se
mostrará quem tem que procurar mostrar
quem não se uma costureira porque na
nuca já experimentei o meia elano que já
não pude não comigo isso nunca aconteceu
acho eu pelo menos nunca ninguém se
queixam porque não tem ninguém da minha
casa sem a peça eu podia perder desafios
como com a peça mas sempre sempre
perfeita cima toda a perfeição e vamos
voltar então na minha história até o
momento foi o programa pra quem não viu
foi um programa que a rtp lançou em 2007
o custo da mão de captura com já
estávamos um caso à parte da cozinha e
culinária por ser uma costura a minha
mais nova
convidam escrever um programa sem saber
depois vem dizer olha foi chamada
perguntar à cinta postura eu consegui
fazer o que eu gosto de fazer nada
acontecia eu ganhar pessoal do norte
nestas coisas não é muito pra ganhar
sempre a ser pago em se matar a freira
mesma manhã
e lá fui al qassim al e acho no cassino
primeiro caso em fish uma das perguntas
que fizeram se calhar por isso porque eu
era como hoje aqui são as mais velhas
naquela ocasião também pode ser que
estavam cá fora da lei da fila mesmo
perguntaram qual era o objetivo que eu
tenho no programa estão ainda que tenha
mostrado e eu simplesmente disse eu
estou aqui para dignificar a profissão
de costureira acho que a nossa produção
está muito mal vista
qualquer pessoa que esse fato foi
mostrar nunca correu certo eu quero
mostrar como é cinco pessoas que
trabalham com gosto complicação e acima
de tudo com perfeição que assim que
trabalha no norte
eu fui para a escola
[Aplausos]
trabalhei muito foi muito duro mas que
eu não percebo a a competir a pensar
quem viu o programa se calhar passou um
pouco isso vem muitas vezes na cabeça
porque o que eu queria acima tudo que é
um programa passar se no referido
popularizar a profissão quis treinar ele
passasse uma imagem de todos
trabalharmos em prol de uma peça
criticar seus ao final do dia da prova e
tivesse uma peça pronta então eu passava
a vida e para competir e ajudar os meus
colegas faziam muitas vezes é porque
está fazendo assim que vai ser assim ea
produção da banda na cabeça não está
aqui para ajudar a evitar a equipa
competitiva nesta premissa acho que se
diz porque eu creio que no fundo todos
sentindo amigos que os treinos e acho
que saíram
acho que sim prontos no final depois
próximas provas ganhas outras nem tanto
o objetivo foi cumprido e ganhei
programa
a muito custo a pensar muito custo era a
única pessoa do norte que sobrou se é
que sobrou lá mas como sou uma pessoa
rija e que agüentou a pressão
psicológica que foi submetida
o trabalho quase a dormir quatro horas
por dia ela foi submetida e eu disse não
sou do norte e sul de manaus
para nós a chuva e sol e eu vou ganhar
esta
esse foi reintegrado depois antes uma
situação que aconteceu a e durante as
gravações e eu posso mudar uma fui
convidada para travar os projetos muito
interessantes no mundo da moda mas que
não passavam por guimarães teria que
ficar a lembrança boa projetos
interessantes mas eu queria e podia
voltar a guimarães com guimarães o que
já acontece aqui na área têxtil e na
moda
eu mesmo estava em casa já nem vou falar
da minha loja nova estava em casa numa
num raio de 15 10 quilômetros do
encontro tudo o que precisa para
trabalhar o texto porque com o país boa
a falta de tudo deve nos treinos a falta
tudo porque conheceu aqui qualquer coisa
que faça falta na minha área e eu tenho
é não precisando da manhã então não tudo
passar por fazer têm que ser eliminados
braga a guimarães para seguir na briga e
então eu resolvi abrir a dar um passo em
frente na minha vida sair do buraco e
abrir o meu próprio espaço abrir o meu
espaço teria que encontrar um sítio um
pouco a minha imagem e que me dissesse
algo podia ter encontrado uma loja no
centro histórico que é lindíssimo 900
histórica do castelo por exemplo mas não
eu escolhi a rua da caldeira ou a o
final da volta à caldeira para abrir o
meu espaço porque procurou da cameron é
uma rotunda diz muito
há 30 anos atrás quando comecei a
trabalhar na rua da caldeira ou aquela
zona transpirava têxtil por todos os
lados
era uma era indústria era tudo lá se
concentrava
hoje passamos lá das ruínas pouco ou
nada resta dessa altura mas eu continuo
a gostar acho que é uma zona que o
ambiente eo tenho idéia a nossa câmera
tem projetos futuros para aquela zona
novamente
então encontramos espaços construiu um
pouco a minha imagem prefeito
sofisticado com bom gosto e acima tudo
preparado pra perceber a quem procura
que é um pouco de todo o lado que não
aparece para trabalhar
estou quase a terminar mas cria só dizia
eu não sou estilista
não sou designer respeito muito os
estilistas que o texto dos designers
suas fantásticas mas eu sou costureira
eu passo possível o que nos dizem não
transforma os desenhos lindíssimos deus
e realidade na perfeição em poucas horas
graças à minha maturidade nesta área e é
isso que eu quero tentar passar minhas
clientes que têm conseguido com como o
trabalho que eu vou conseguindo fazer
com elas tenham criatividade sim posso
ser titular do costureiro criativa mas
quando a gente quando fazemos o que
gostamos quando estamos na área
conquistados porque independentemente da
área qualquer um de vocês escolherem
façam bem feito é isso destaca dos
outros
é isso que destaca das outras costeiras
temos que chamar o que estamos a fazer e
fazer bem feito e aquela peça não tiver
a nossa imagem é proferida no dia
seguinte ter perdido um dia de trabalho
acho que esta esteja exatamente uma
cliente 115 e iii isso não tinha
é isso que eu faço transforma os sonhos
e realidade alguns desenhos que trazem
tanto que cada pessoa sair de lá com uma
peça tal como as ofertas com uma peça a
sua vida exclusivamente trabalhada para
ela pensada para ela e bonita pra poder
fazer o que fizeram ao mês
acho que é dentro dessa peça diz
objetivo que eu trabalho
o programa de uma notoriedade que
realmente precisam precisei parar pra
pensar esta esta segunda fase da minha
vida foi foi mal uma aventura mas eu
estava em casa tirar 20 anos que não
falava com ninguém ter que te maneira se
no mundo foi foi foi muito bom foi bom
conhecer pessoas de outras de outras
zonas
estávamos todos a mesma em artes e acho
que fiz bem
não não dignifica a imagem de guimarães
acha que não não disse nada ia à minha
história espero que tenham gostado
[Aplausos]